Paul Joseph watson is an author and the
editor at large of infowars.com
and prisonplanet.com.
Paul,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Hi Dave.
Good to be here.
I'm glad you are here.
When we were talking before we started,
you were saying that I'm going to get.
I'm going to get some hate for this.
Are you warning me of pre hate?
I think you've probably already got some
hate just for announcing that I'm going
to be on.
I mean there's a lot of people who have
some kind of pull her over for wars and
Alex Jones I think is,
you know,
conspiracy central,
but most people don't realize that,
you know,
Alex is not this big main controlling
force like dictating what everybody
says.
He pretty much gives me free reign to
talk about whatever I want and that's
what's good about info wars.
It's a very broad church.
So you've got,
you know,
numerous reits as commentators who
worked with him for wars and they can
basically talk about and write about
whatever they want.
So as far as I'm concerned,
that's the best job imaginable.
So I think people need to get over it
and move on because the sun is that
we're talking about supersede any
perception about what info wars is
about,
what people think it's about.
So you know,
I just want people to listen to what
I've got to say and concentrate on the
sun rather than,
you know,
what website is hosted on that's
irrelevant at the end of the day.
Right.
And that's exactly what happened.
I mean I just sent one tweet out this
morning saying that you were coming on
the show and immediate conspiracy
theorist,
he works with Alex Jones and it's like
you guys are having conspiracy theories
about the conspiracy theory.
So I was like,
you know,
let's just talk it out and we'll see
what happens.
Right.
No,
it's not as bad as it used to be.
I mean I know there's this perception
out there that,
you know,
Info wars is discredited or whatever,
but I mean when breaking stuff every
day.
Well linked on the drudge report,
you know,
we've got 20 million listeners a week
now for the radio show.
So whether you like cars or not,
wherever a presence and you know,
that's why some people have a problem
with it,
but as I said,
just concentrate on the issues of what
I'm saying and in fact my youtube
channel explores these kinds of issues
off on a tangent from the normal content
that info was,
would cover.
So I've kind of attracted a new
satellite audience outside of Info wars,
so it's all about bringing new people in
and that's why I've attempted to do,
that's where I think I've been
successful recently.
Yeah.
And it's your youtube channel that
actually got me familiar with what you
were doing because you did a phenomenal
video on the regressive left,
which everyone knows.
I'm not a fan of them.
You've done some really interesting
stuff about the European immigration
crisis.
So yeah,
we're going to get into all the issues
stuff.
Uh,
but just to wrap up the info wars part
of this,
how did you get involved with Info wars?
What's your relationship like with Alex?
Let's go down that route for a little
bit.
Well,
I mean I started my own political
website when I was about 18 years old,
so you know,
I would go home and host a radio show on
dial up internet to three people,
two listeners,
you know,
back in the early two thousands.
So that was the very genesis of Alex
liked what he was doing.
He liked the content I was covering,
so he basically headhunted me and said,
you know,
coming in and edit info was coming right
for us.
And that's,
that's what happened.
So now I'm based in London.
They're based in Austin,
Texas,
so I'm a,
you know,
six hours ahead of time so I can get a
jump on the news that's always
beneficial with a news organization.
So that's why it kind of works and he
lets me write and say what I want.
He's not this controlling presence and
you know,
a lot of people think that Alex Jones is
a kind of act that it's put on this
radio personality that he has.
But if you meet him and you hang around
with him,
what you see is what you get.
That's how I like joke.
He's like that all the time.
It's not an act.
He's not putting it on,
you know,
in,
in private,
in person.
He's kind of more jovial and fun than
his rants on the radio would suggest,
but that's him.
That's his personality.
It's not an act.
Yeah.
I'm curious,
were you trepidatious to,
to join forces with him because
obviously it was a good opportunity.
It's saying that it's worked for you.
Uh,
but because of what I said before about
I just send one tweet out and people
start yelling at me.
You must have had some level of concern.
Right?
Well that was,
that was a long time ago,
back in the day.
So really Alex was only a few years into
his operation.
I built up a good deal of traffic with
my own website.
So there was no trepidation.
It was just about reaching a wider
audience.
So obviously I jumped at the
opportunity.
Yeah.
So where do you actually consider
yourself politically?
I think I have a good sense and one of
the things we've been talking about here
is sort of this new growing center.
People who really want to stand up for
free speech and civil liberties,
but also understand that we have real
threats and that this immigration issue
in Europe is a big problem.
They want to be able to honestly talk
about Islam.
Islam.
So the old dynamic of right,
left Democrat,
conservative for us in the states.
It all seems to be crumbling.
So I'm curious,
what do you even consider yourself if,
if you had to go with a label?
Um,
well,
I grew up,
obviously when I was a teenager I was a
progressive and I think it was Winston
Churchill that said,
if you're not a liberal when you're
young,
you have no heart if you're not a
conservative when you get older,
you have no brain.
So a moment in my thirties I would
consider myself mainly a limited area
and maybe you could call me a
conservative area,
but it's somewhere within that gap
between the two.
So that's basically where I'm at right
now.
Yeah.
Do you find that movement growing,
uh,
where you are?
Because I do sense it's growing here.
You know,
our politics have gotten so crazy,
uh,
between a democratic socialist who's the
hot guy on the left and trump who is
sort of off the rails but confused,
you know,
is he really a Republican?
Does he stand for conservative values or
is he truly a centrist?
None of it makes sense anymore.
Are you guys getting some of that
feeling too?
So some,
some extent.
Yeah,
but I mean in the UK it's still
extremely left wing.
I mean even,
even the Tory party isn't classically
conservative.
They're somewhat left on a lot of Su,
so most people don't even know what a
libertarian is in the UK,
to be honest,
the only people who are really
politically active will know what that
actually means.
So I think America is streets ahead in
the sense of actually understanding that
there is a political alternative outside
of progressivism,
which is still what dominates the entire
discourse in the UK.
I mean people will think you're a racist
or a bigger if you're not a progressive,
especially as a young person.
So the circles in which I move,
there's very little understanding about
what these labels mean,
which is why I try to concentrate on the
issues without,
you know,
coming at it from a left or right
persuasion.
Yeah.
And that's very much what I've tried to
do and I've tried to define a lot of
these terms and you know,
the whole Libertarian ideology really
fits with me,
you know what I mean?
Like do with your body what you want,
let the government stay out of your life
for the most part and,
and build a life that works for you.
But you're saying that that the idea of
that is really gone in the UK now.
I don't really.
I don't think it was ever here really.
I don't think people came to grips with
it.
Yeah.
I mean there's still,
there's still some debate within
libertarian circles about certain issues
like abortion or like open borders.
I mean some Libertarians think that to
be truly classically libertarian you
have to advocate open borders.
Other people say,
well,
no,
that's the government foisting open
borders upon the people,
you know,
taking their tax money to pay for it,
but I mean within the UK,
as far as I'm concerned,
in my experience,
these,
these labels aren't even known,
they're not even defined.
So when you describe yourself as a
libertarian,
people have no frame of reference,
so they think if you're not a liberal,
then you must be on some obscure fringe
of the political spectrum.
But you know,
I guess the,
the understanding is growing,
especially with the backlash against
social justice warriors,
which has really accelerated in the past
18 months.
So now these issues are,
uh,
beginning to be brought to the fore.
Now people are beginning to understand
that libertarianism is a backlash
against authoritarianism,
which of course is embodied by this
feminist third wave feminist social
justice warrior movement.
Yeah,
you're,
you're hitting all the buzzwords there.
So do you think it's really just a
branding issue for Libertarians?
Because there's sort of no unifying
principle that's bringing us together
other than do what you'd like and don't
harm someone.
So they just need sort of better.
There are a good reps basically,
or at least from what I see in the
United States,
we have a couple of Gary Johnson,
former governor of New Mexico,
had on the show and he's running for
president,
but it's hard to gain traction when
you're one of the outsiders.
Yeah.
I was thinking the problem with
libertarianism is they're not on the
frontier of political discourse.
So when you get major issues that crop
up in the news media,
obviously as somebody who's politically
active,
you have to seize upon them and tell
your story and try and control change
that narrative as best you see fit.
But Libertarians tend to get stuck in
the weeds,
you know,
they're always arguing with each other
about these new issues and they're not
really on the frontier of the cultural
discourse,
which is more,
you know,
now the domain of,
of conservative areas and people who
oppose social justice warriors.
So I think in America the libertarian
movement is still so stuck in the weeds
and arguing,
you know,
my new shit between themselves that
they're not really,
um,
a robust forces they could be.
I think that's one region in which they
could improve by hijacking these key
issues,
these core issues like the migrant
crisis and they're not doing that,
that they're debating with each other
over what minute ism is and whether we
should have no government or limited
government and they have speeches and
three our youtube conversations about
that and they're not really reaching
anyone outside their inner circle.
So I think that's how,
you know,
libertarianism needs to improve in that
way.
So I guess the silver lining to all of
this is that because of the social
justice warrior thing and now we can get
into some of these issues is they're
starting to push people into this idea
of libertarianism,
which is nice.
So let's,
let's go to the social justice warrior
stuff.
You are not a fan of the social justice
warrior movement to put it mildly.
Uh,
when,
when did you wake up to it?
When did you really see it as,
as a threat to free speech?
I think it was probably made 2014.
I mean,
I was,
I was mainly covering geopolitical
issues back in 2012,
2013.
I was mainly on the Syrian civil war,
the buildup,
the arms race that the confrontation
with Russia over the course of 2013 to
2014 and then I became more active on
twitter and it's only when you become
active on twitter and you have to
actually put some time into it and
follow the discourse that's taking place
on twitter that you realize that these
issues are important because it's no
longer just,
you know,
demented 14 year olds on tumbler
expressing that bizarre arcane
grievances.
These people are in the universities.
They are our future thought leaders that
are being cuddled.
They're being protected by professors at
these major universities.
So it was that connection between
realizing that this is not just idiots
within opinion on twitter,
which is completely obscure.
This is now a really robust driving
narrative,
uh,
with,
amongst millennials.
And that's,
once you realize that once you realize
how it's,
how it's infested the core of the
education system in America and now in
Britain as well,
that to me really symbolized how
important it was to oppose these people
because they oppose everything I stand
for.
You know,
within the tenets of libertarianism
itself.
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting because I had very
similar,
probably around the same time a
awakening about this because it was a
lot on twitter,
right?
Because you're seeing this stuff on
twitter and you see the stuff from
tumbler that makes its way over and all
these people fighting about this stuff
that we hear about the trigger warnings
and safe spaces and all of this stuff.
But I could never really figure out how
much of this just existed for people
behind computers.
But basically what you're saying is that
there's been.
This has been a long time coming and
that's what sorta has seeped into the
university space.
Right?
Right.
And now it's becoming really physical.
I mean,
you've seen the Bernie Sanders people
and we're going to get into the whole
trump thing lights,
uh,
but we've sent.
Our reporters are to Wisconsin this past
week,
for example.
And you know,
it's not just Bernie Sanders supporters,
it's leftist in general than other ones.
Vial,
hateful people you could ever wish to
meet.
I mean,
the Shia hatred that they give you like
radiates from their eyes when you so
much as disagree with them is palpable
and now they're out there.
They're shutting down these private
functions,
these Donald Trump events,
which,
whether you agree with trump or not,
that's not your free speech First
Amendment right to shut down a private
function.
You're impinging on other people's First
Amendment by doing that.
And these people wave signs saying,
you know,
oppose hatred or bigotry that have the
most hateful people you could imagine.
So that's what I see now,
the translation from twitter,
now they're getting out on the streets
of girls.
We've seen that with black lives matter
that metastasized into a similar,
hateful,
violent movement.
And we might get into that later.
But yeah,
it's,
it's manifesting physically now.
And it's why people are worried about
civil unrest and riots quite frankly
because these people are prone to
violence and they're very hateful
people.
So.
Okay,
so we're gonna get into all of that.
So.
But you hit on a lot of things there.
So one of the things that I've been
saying is I can't believe we're at a
place in 2016 in America where I fear
that it will be us ourselves,
the citizens who will take away our
right to free speech more than the
government.
So in other words,
it's not a first amendment issue in
these people protest because it's not
the government doing it,
but we do have a certain social contract
that you have to let people speak and
then you can use your speech to
counteract it.
But basically you're saying by blocking
roads and by stopping people from
speaking that that's where it becomes a
free speech issue,
not necessarily a first amendment issue.
Right.
You see that distinction?
No,
I've got no problem with people being
out on the streets protesting.
I mean that's the riots when they
actually go Donald Trump events in
private buildings where they've paid to
hire this building and they got the
event in Chicago canceled,
for example,
that's impinging on other,
on other people's rights to peaceably
assemble exercise their first amendment
and just listen to somebody's speech.
But I mean,
as you touched on before,
it's this whole idea of,
you know,
before the,
the power was in the media and we're
going to talk about in the media later,
now it's,
it's kind of invested back into the
hands of people.
It's people power,
but it's people power gone mad.
So now you have organized groups of
people who go out to publicly shame
others to get them fired,
to censor content from the Internet.
And that's how twitter in one sense
empowered the people.
But it gave that power to these
perpetually outraged mobs.
And that's what woke me up to the social
justice warrior Su,
because as you said it,
the concern for me for a few years ago
was the states,
the government impinging on our free
speech rights.
Now it's perpetually professionally
outraged mobs impinging on our free
speech rights.
I think that's the biggest danger right
now in 2016 in comparison to anything
that the state's going to do.
I completely agree.
It's so ironic.
I can't even think of an example right
now in America where the state is
holding the first amendment hostage.
I can't find one instance where you
can't say whatever you want about the
government or about government officials
or anything like that,
but I can see many instances where the
mob and the online mob and they'll try
to stop your patrion funding if you're a
youtuber or they'll try to figure out
other ways to have you fired or shamed
or whatever else.
Do you think that these people,
like for example,
when trump was doing the rally in
Arizona and they blocked the road in
Arizona,
do you think that they thought that they
were helping their cause because I get
it,
but not all of these people are thinking
all their moves through properly and
they know they're going out.
We're going to stop them from showing up
and that's all good,
but to me all they really do is
strengthened trump because then look,
nobody that didn't get there is suddenly
not gonna vote for trump.
It makes them want to vote for trump
more than everyone watching it on the
news is going,
wow,
who's being oppressed here?
It's actually trump,
so it's really.
It's fascinating,
right?
No,
I don't know if they've got any idea of
how ridiculous they look,
but they've got this media narrative
backing them up,
which is that trump is inciting violence
and this is something that I've been hot
on.
Again,
I don't agree with trump on everything.
I'm not a vehement trump supporter,
but if you go on twitter on any single
day and search for assassinate trump or
kill trump,
you will find hundreds and hundreds of
examples.
Obviously most people don't mean it.
They're not going to do anything,
but they're threatening to assassinate
trump and yet the whole media narrative
is about how trump supports as a violent
about how trump himself is inciting
violence.
There's a video on youtube right now and
we complain about,
you know,
to a TSA censoring conservatives for
having the wrong political opinion.
There's a guy who's still on twitter.
His account hasn't been touched by the
trust and safety council.
Yeah.
He's got a youtube video which calls for
caving.
Trump's head in with a shovel,
shooting him with an AK 47.
Filling him full of bullets is not even
age restricted on Youtube.
I mean,
I've had videos age restricted for swear
words and the media came out afterwards.
This is a rap video out of a Baltimore
unbuildable dot.
Come celebrate today as a powerful
protest song.
This is a group of young men in a rap
video threatening to kill Donald Trump.
Imagine if you know the Oregon militia
or whoever had come out with a video
threatening to assassinate Hillary
Clinton.
Do you think the media would be
celebrating it as a powerful protest
song?
So it's that double standard they're
given left media cover because we've got
this narrative that trump's inciting
violence when again,
they're the most hateful violent people
out there.
Well,
it's so fascinating because as you've
repeated several times,
now,
you're not even a huge trump supporter,
and yet you're,
you are put in a position where you have
to defend some of these ideals.
I'm not a trump supporter and I,
I feel the same way.
If I want to stand up for the ideals
that I stand for,
I have to call this nonsense out because
apparently no one in the media do it.
You know,
there's another great example of that.
Did you see a couple of weeks ago when
that guy tried to bum rush trump on
stage and then the next night he was on
cnn and all the news channels and they
were treating him as if he was some
legit voice of counter protests,
but meanwhile he was trying to attack a
presidential candidate whether you like
trump or not.
Right?
So this is.
This is fully the fault of the media
here,
right?
Well,
exactly.
I mean you flip it around if,
if a right winger tried to attack Bernie
Sanders or Hillary Clinton,
that he wouldn't be on CNN the next day
being given a complimentary welcoming
platform.
Yet we see this again and again and you
know,
trump is a creation of social justice
warriors at the end of the day have
reaction as an equal and opposite
reaction and people are just tired.
That tired of being lectured about how
racist they are.
They're tired about being lectured to
check their privilege and whether you
agree with trump or not,
and I don't agree with them on things
like torture or surveillance,
but this is the backlash.
You know,
these people who support trump,
uh,
so condescended towards by the
mainstream media,
but they had to work for everything they
had.
These are mainly quite poor blue collar
workers,
the supporting trump,
but they're sick of being made to feel
guilty about who they are,
but the establishment still doesn't
recognize that fact and just labels them
racists and bigots.
They still don't get it.
They still don't get what's driving this
phenomenon.
And it might end up,
you know,
slapping them in the face.
Yeah.
Well I think it,
it slapping them in the face right now.
So how much of this do you think his
establishment politicians and just the
establishment on both the Democrats and
the Republicans in bed with the media,
that they've all gotten so fat for so
long that they've all just asked
terrible questions and no good follow
ups and they've all just been in this
game for so long that they.
Their fear of trump is that he's going
to leave a lot of these guys without a
job.
A lot of these pundits on TV and all
these people who have professionally
gotten everything wrong for years,
but they've had a gig and a lot of these
people I think think,
Whoa,
I'm not going to have a gig if trump
gets in.
So they're.
They're protecting their own assets more
than anything else.
Well,
that's definitely part of it.
I mean,
the other department is,
you know,
trump is self funded.
He's a maverick.
He might be a rich,
bigoted buffoon,
but he's unpredictable and the elite,
the establishment of the political
establishment is used to having not one
but two candidates and every single
presidential race that they control.
I mean,
you go back to 2004 Bush and Kerry,
both skull and bones members.
That's,
you know,
that's business as usual for the
political elite.
Somebody like trump comes along,
he's a,
he's a loose cannon.
He's unpredictable.
They don't know what he's going to do.
I think if he got in power,
he would immediately start moderating
his rhetoric or whatever.
They're scared stiff because it's simply
an unknown quantity.
And as you said,
a lot of people in the establishment who
have relied on this status quo for so
long,
for decades,
an hour petrified because you know,
he's,
he's come along and up the apple
applecart people are scared.
Yeah.
So do you view this all is just a big
negotiating ploy with him because you
know,
I was seeing this week he made this
comment that,
you know,
maybe Japan should have nukes and
everyone is saying,
well then he's going to start a nuclear
arms race.
But what he really was saying was either
Japan should be able to defend itself
with nukes because North Korea is there
and China and everything else.
Or they should pay us to defend them,
meaning pay the United States because we
basically have agreements that we defend
them militarily.
So it's not that crazy of a proposal
that we should be paid.
You know,
if you're a celebrity,
you pay your body guard.
Right?
So do you think a lot of this is that he
just throws this stuff out there,
then gets misquoted.
You know what I mean?
The media runs with a tie.
He really wants to start a nuclear arms
race and then people.
It even strengthens him more because
then people go,
wait a minute.
That wasn't that crazy of a proposal.
No,
they just run with the banner headline
that suits their agenda and as you said,
if you actually drill down into what
he's saying,
sometimes it makes a lot of sense.
Sometimes he just missed,
speaks and tylee back a few months ago
and he advocated bringing in Syrian
refugees and within 24 hours completely
reversed his position.
So it's partly that,
but geo politically from a geopolitical
standpoint is better than anyone else.
And definitely Hilary Clinton.
I mean they call it trump is laminate
phobic.
He's not the one who voted for a wall
that killed a million Muslims.
You know,
he's not the one that supported regime
change in Syria and Libya that led to
this migrant crisis in the first place.
Hillary Clinton did.
He's not the one who's amping up for
world war three with Russia as every
other single gop candidate has during
the debates.
So if you want to talk,
I mean there's all this rhetoric about,
you know,
trump,
the world's going to explode the day
trump gets into office because he's so
crazy and out of control.
If you actually look at his prior record
and what he's advocating in terms of
America's military role in the world,
it's the most peaceful,
definitely out of all the gop candidates
and definitely over and above Hillary
Clinton who voted for the Iraq war.
You know,
it's funny,
I was at a very liberal progressive la
party this weekend and people were
freaking out over trump and I kept
trying to say to them,
guys,
if you fear trump,
if you're a liberal or a progressive or
anyone on the left,
you should fear Ted Cruz far more than
you fear Donald trump.
But I couldn't get people to quite
understand why.
And I'm,
I'm sort of amazed by that.
Well,
it's because they don't read.
I mean not.
Hi Guys.
They don't read beyond headlines.
And if you actually listened to trump
speeches,
which he rambles on for an hour or so,
but if you actually listened to most of
them,
most of his speeches,
a devoted to things like trade deals,
I mean this is why people are voting for
him.
It's the reaction to the lost jobs,
to the ruined towns in middle America
because of Nafta,
because of these trade deals that have
screwed them over.
If you map his supporters,
it correlates almost directly with the
industrial,
the industrialization and despair.
These areas of America that have been
completely abandoned,
completely left to rot by these trade
deals that have resulted in the great
sucking sound of these jobs leaving
America.
So watch his speeches.
They are liberal.
A progressive will never watch his
speeches.
It's not mainly about building a wall.
It's not mainly about banning Muslims.
It's mainly about trade.
And that's why he has a lot of support
amongst blue collar workers because
people's jobs have been shipped abroad
and they're furious about it.
And that's mainly a left wing position
to be complaining about.
Life has been in the past.
So That's interesting that most liberals
just aren't aware of the main body of
his actual speech and why people are
attracted to his campaign.
Well that's like when you know,
they'll tweet out,
they'll say,
oh look,
trump ties are made in Mexico.
And they say,
oh,
what a hypocrite he is.
But that doesn't improve.
He's a hypocrite.
That shows he's a good businessman.
He's used are shitty trade deals that
our politicians have signed to make
money here and he's saying I will change
those deals.
So people like me won't have to do that
somehow.
That's lost on all my liberal friends.
No matter how many times I bring that
up.
Exactly.
And also what's lost,
if you look at the lines of people going
into these trump events,
which again,
we've had reports in Wisconsin this
week,
you know,
a lot of Asian Americans,
quite a few black people in fight back
when Rubio was in the rice,
trump had more than double the support
for Muslim Americans than every other
gop candidate combined.
He set to break records for black votes
to support for a Republican candidate.
So again,
this narrative that it's just about
bigotry and racism is just surface crap.
You delve a little bit below and you
have to understand the wider phenomenon,
why he has this support.
This is our complete political
revolution.
This is about an overthrow of the status
quo.
Americans are sick of it.
And now finally that putting that vote
behind it,
whether it be for trump or sanders.
Yeah.
So let's move away from trump a little
bit.
I want to back up to something you said
about Hillary.
So Hillary in your eyes,
uh,
because of obviously all the connections
between her husband and the
establishment connections that she's
been involved in this forever from being
a first lady to a senator and secretary
of state and all that.
She's absolutely who the establishment
wants.
Right?
Do you see any wiggle room on that?
Oh No.
Why the establishment behind Hillary?
100 percent.
I mean,
I went to build a Burg in a,
it was Denmark in 2014,
Austria.
Two thousand and 50.
And even back then we got the inside
leak from the Bilderberg group meeting,
which is this conference at 120
influential bankers,
politicians,
academics,
and even back then they had come
together and said,
Hillary's,
I pick for 2016,
we're going to try and defund all her
competition.
So years back,
Hillary was there,
pick,
I mean,
in 2008,
she took the fall for Obama and that was
decided.
It's a meeting in chantilly,
coincidentally,
the same location where the Bilderberg
meeting was taking place back in 2018.
So yeah,
Hillary's been a shoe in for a long time
now for the elite.
So where does this put sanders in your
mind?
Because look,
he wants a lot of the changes,
you know,
ironically,
sanders and trump are talking about a
lot of the same stuff,
right?
They both want to severely changed the
power structure,
changed the system,
yet their supporters seemed to
absolutely hate each other.
Um,
so I suspect you agree with some of the
heart of sanders,
just not the policy.
I can't bring myself to agree with
somebody who says that bread lines
aren't necessarily a bad thing.
I mean,
this idea that Bernie Sanders
supporters,
if he loses to Hillary,
which looks like it's almost certainly
going to happen and then going to go and
vote for trump because he's the other
antiestablishment option,
I just don't buy that because for the
very reason you just said they
absolutely hated each other.
I don't think many of Bernie Sanders
supporters a rarely jive with his
antiestablishment credit.
I think they jive more with this extreme
left wing social justice warrior,
pro socialist pro,
massive welfare state position,
which I can't bring myself to agree
with,
but just from the behavior of his
supporters over the past couple of
months has really turned me off to
anything that Bernie Sanders stands for.
Unfortunately.
You know,
it's really interesting.
I don't know that I've ever felt this
way about a candidate and I don't even
know that I could have made this up,
but I like him more than I liked the
reasons that people are supporting him.
I think,
and this is what I was telling Milo
Yiannopoulos a couple of weeks ago,
I think he himself is a decent guy,
whether I disagree with him or not,
but the underpinnings of what he's
bringing I think are really dangerous
and that's what I fear and that's a
strange place to feel about a candidate
when you like them,
but you don't like what they're sort of
bringing along with them.
I don't know that I've ever felt that
way before about somebody.
Well,
no,
and it's the same reason that the trump
phenomenon has happened.
I mean,
he's not,
you can't control it.
He's a maverick.
He's unpredictable.
They wouldn't be able to buy him off.
So whatever his policies,
which I fundamentally disagree with,
you still represents a threats of the
establishment because he's an unknown
quantity.
So I mean that's,
that's why sanders has paralleled the
trump phenomenon,
but you know,
as the way it looks now,
he's basically no chance.
So it remains to be seen what's going to
happen to his voters,
but I very much doubt they're going to
go over to trump in the kind of numbers
that people are suggesting.
Right.
So with the sanders people,
my sense is that a lot of them really
want to just burn the system down and
that's sort of why I can't get behind
them because yeah,
we have a lot of problems in America.
We've done bad things internationally.
There's too much money in politics.
We need a fair economic system or all
kinds of stuff that I can get on board
with the ideas of what he says.
But there's still something pretty good
here in America and I think we forget
that as Americans.
And that's what I fear is that these
people want to actually burn the system
down and I'm afraid if you burn it down,
what rises out of those ashes is not
gonna be any better or at least the
chances of it being any better or not.
Very good.
Well,
when his support as a carrying around
hammer and sickle communist flags and
talking about a socialist revolution,
I mean that gives me the jitters.
I mean you can look at sanders
personally,
you know,
he didn't have a job until he was 40
years old.
He was basically a mom living on the
flaws of other people's palms.
So it's personal lifestyle kind of turns
me off towards him as well.
But as you said,
the kind of things,
his support as advocate or in many cases
a lot worse than what he's advocating.
So they want to tear the system down,
but they basically want to replace it
with outright communism.
A lot of them,
and again,
it goes back to this,
you know,
resist capitalism.
Hashtag that was on twitter a couple of
months ago.
These people are,
you know,
they're probably aged 20 to 30.
They've got no idea whatsoever.
The absolute horror that communism has
role on the world over the last 50,
60 years.
And we keep having to,
you know,
have that debate over and over again of
why communism is bad and why leaving
people to their own devices and building
a free market economy is good because
there's this fundamental ignorance
surrounding capitalism.
People think that the system of
capitalism we've got now is free market
capitalism.
It isn't,
it's corporatism crony capitalism,
but they think that that's free market
capitalism,
which is why they go to the extreme
other end of the equation and think that
communism is the solution.
When history has proven that it's not,
we keep having to recycle that argument
over and over again because a lot of
these millennials just don't know the
history,
right?
So instead of detangling some of the
crony capitalism and some of the Wall
Street money and all that stuff,
which he talks about,
which is extremely legit,
they go,
we're going to burn the whole thing
down.
We're going to become communists,
which is crazy.
All right,
so a lot of the Bernie support is
obviously a mixed with the black lives
matter support.
And,
you know,
one of the things I've been saying about
the black lives matter movement is their
intentions are good and somehow what's
happened to the movement seems to have
been hijacked or derailed by,
I think,
what you would call far leftists.
Um,
do you agree with that or do you think
the movement was always that way?
Where do you see it now?
Where do you see it going?
Well,
I mean,
back in 2013,
2014,
myself and Info wars were on the
forefront of exposing police brutality.
I mean probably 25 percent of my content
every day was about police brutality.
Now that,
that whole narrative has been hijacked
by black lives matter.
It makes you less enthusiastic to
actually talk about police brutality,
the effect that they've had.
And the polls show this is massive
support for police departments across
the United States because the tactics
that they engage in a so divisive and
turn ordinary Americans off to such a
degree that now a lot of people simply
would immediately support the police
even in a flagrant case of police
brutality.
So you know,
yeah,
you have to go back to the founding of
black lives matter,
obviously a lot of well meaning people
jumped on board in the first six months
or so,
but the inspiration behind black lives
matter,
and this is the woman that the three
female founders of that embryonic group
said was their inspiration,
was a woman named the softer Chicago.
Now she's on the FBI's most wanted
terrorist list because she killed a cop
in New Jersey back in the seventies and
then fled to Cuba.
This is a woman who's,
you know,
black lives matter activists.
They invoke her name at nearly every
rally.
She's a domestic terrorist who left the
Black Panther party because it wasn't
violent enough.
She joined the Black Liberation Army.
You know,
this was another domestic terror group
that was involved in bombings and
assassinations,
killing police officers.
So when you have that kind of guru,
that inspiration behind the movement,
obviously it's going to tend towards
violence.
You had black lives matter protesters in
New York walking down the street
chanting,
what do we want?
Dead Cops.
When do we want them?
Now?
That's the only going to turn people
away from your movement.
So it's not an inclusive movement.
It's been a divisive movement since
almost the beginning since just after
the first ferguson protests and it's
only got worse as it's been hijacked by
all these opportunists and operatives.
Yeah.
So for you,
as you said,
you guys were ahead on this stuff and I
remember seeing a lot of videos that you
guys were doing where you were talking
about police brutality before it had
really bubbled up into the mainstream
news,
so it must be extremely depressing for
you as someone that is in this and you
talk about this,
you understand that there was something
good here and as you just laid out that
it has been derailed.
How do you,
how do you get it back to that is,
is it too late?
Is the.
Is the wave already gone to to get it
back to what was right?
Dealing with legit issues about police
brutality?
Well,
when the entire movement Blm was founded
on this Michael Brown case,
the whole hands up don't shoot mess and
the media pedaled that for six months or
more,
the autopsy,
of course it turned out that was
complete bs.
He never had his hands are,
so they base all their grievances on
these completely fraudulent cases and
then you have a case like Eric Garner,
which was a,
you know,
a legitimate acts of police brutality,
which we support the victim in that
case,
but they tend to base all their
grievances on these ridiculous cases
that are obviously justified use of
force by the police.
So it's difficult to see how we're going
to get back to,
uh,
a rational conversation about it when
these people are,
you know,
invoking the inspiration,
the guru or the domestic terrorists,
they're chanting for dead cops.
You know,
you had people planned to bomb the
Ferguson police station.
You had the cops that were killed in New
York as part of a black lives matter,
revenge attack by Ishmael Brinsley.
So when it attracts those kinds of
extremists,
I mean at this point,
I call it a domestic hate group,
if this was a bunch of why Oregon
militia members who were chanting for
black cops to killed black people to be
killed,
who some of them were actually planning
to do that and who's ideological
inspiration was?
Timothy Mcveigh for example,
the media wouldn't get behind that,
but we've seen elements of the media get
behind black lives matter.
We've seen,
you know,
Time magazine,
Time magazine in defense of rioting.
So they built this whole grievance
industry.
It was supported by some elements of the
this media and now you've got Hillary
Clinton meeting with black lives,
meet a is back a few months ago saying
she's prepared to change laws for them.
I think this is very divisive
destructive movement and it's
de-legitimized genuine opposition to
police brutality,
which was an su and continues to be an
Su,
but now people are so turned off towards
that.
As I said,
the polls show that people don't like
black lives matter.
They're now more likely to support
police.
Yeah.
You know,
a perfect example of that would be sort
of what you alluded to,
which is what happened in Oregon here,
what two months ago when you know the
cliven Bundy people,
they took over basically a vacant lot
house office and everyone I saw,
all my progressive friends were
screaming about what terrorists they are
domestic terrorists.
I'm not defending them.
They walked into a federal building.
Even if nobody was there in the door,
was unlocked with weapons and I think
maybe one person did die somehow related
to it or something that.
You could correct me if I'm wrong on
that,
but there was such outrage over that
where there was virtually no violence.
I'm not defending everything that they
did versus the lack of outrage when
there's actual violence.
So everything comes down to race at the
end of the day with the progresses.
Right.
Well,
yeah,
that was a.
That was a young guy hold up there in
the,
in the wildlife center,
right at the end of that situation who
was threatening to kill himself and it
was being broadcast live on the
Internet.
It was [inaudible].
It was a tragic situation,
but on twitter you had all the
regressive,
celebrating it,
calling him a racist and saying you
should shoot himself in the head.
You hadn't Lavoy finicum who was in the
vehicle with a couple of these other
protests as females traveling through.
They say FBI roadblock.
He gets out of the car,
he gets gunned down.
God knows two dozen times or whatever.
That was a shady situation,
but again,
as you said,
a complete lack of outrage.
They filled the car with bullets.
It's a.
it's a surprise that these are the women
who were unarmed and we're not showing
any resistance,
didn't get slaughtered themselves,
but on the left there was no outrage
whatsoever because they weren't black.
I think we should treat everybody who's
a victim of police brutality the same
regardless of race,
but because they don't do that,
it turns white middle class America away
from their movement and it prevents us
from becoming truly united and
addressing police brutality.
Yeah,
I mean that's it right there.
There are unintended consequences of
what they do actually drive drive people
the other way.
What would you say to.
I have progressive friends,
most of them,
well,
most of them are talk to me anymore,
but I had progressive friends that when
we,
when we discuss this stuff,
they would say,
well,
a certain amount of violence.
If you really want social change,
a certain amount of violence is
necessary.
Do you buy that at all or do you think
that's just an excuse because look,
you're not going to get headlines If,
if there isn't a certain amount of
violence,
right?
If you just have a peaceful protest,
the media doesn't show up.
Well,
I believe in nonviolent civil
disobedience.
I mean,
if you look at everyone throughout
history who actually change society,
if you look at it,
you know Gandhi or Martin Luther King,
who now the progressives are trying to
disavow because he wasn't inclusive of
transgender people,
then you don't need the results of
violence because that causes powerful
enough.
When people become a threat to the
establishment.
When the united black people,
when are unite white people,
when they unite people from different
political persuasions,
they don't become a threat when they
results of violence because they can be
easily demonized,
dealt with by the state.
So no,
I don't think that's a terrible idea.
I think it's going to be unsuccessful.
Yeah.
And it's also directly linked into why
these regressives and now we can get
into the regressives.
Somehow we did 45 minutes.
We barely said the word progressive,
uh,
why they label everyone you me,
everybody else as bigots and racists and
everything else because they are,
they can't control people without
splitting us all down into the little
racial markers or you know,
this one's oppressed more than the know
the,
as somebody keeps saying the,
uh,
the oppression Olympics basically.
So let's talk about the regressives.
Was your wake up to them at the exact
same time as you sort of woke up to the
social justice warrior stuff?
Or did it come a little bit after that?
When you really saw that there was this
group of people that was,
was protecting and pushing this
ideology?
Well,
it probably correlates with the rise of
Isis with these terrorist attacks in
Europe with the migrant crisis and the
fight that we're importing people from
bad cultures and I mean that's the heart
of regressive.
You itself proclaimed liberals who
defend and tolerate non liberal
ideologies and I think because at their
heart,
their cultural relativist,
right?
They believe that all cultures are
equal.
Well,
I don't believe that.
I think there are bad cultures and good
cultures.
I made a video a few days ago.
Some cultures are better than others,
but at the heart of progressivism is
this idea of utopianism,
so there can't be such a thing as a bad
culture accepting the fact that there
are bad cultures,
demolishes,
utopianism,
so that's why progressive so cold
progressive's column entertain the fact
that there are bad cultures.
Even for a second,
even though that blatantly off.
I mean,
you know,
when US troops blew the whistle on how
Afghan police officers,
we're bringing young boys onto the army
base and raping them and they were told
to shut up about it because that was
part of their culture.
I think that's a bad culture.
You know when UNICEF has to do pr
campaigns to educate 600 million
Indians,
half of their population,
not to deprecate in the street because
it's causing deadly infections and child
malnutrition.
That's a bad culture.
We need to call out bad cultures because
I don't think importing them into the
West is compatible with western ideals
of,
you know,
liberal tolerance,
but the regressives can't entertain that
for a second because their cultural
relativists they can't entertain the
notion that some cultures are better
than others,
which is why in Germany for example,
these migrants that came in and started
deprecating and hot tubs,
started masturbating in swimming pools,
started raping children in swimming
pools.
One of the swimming pools in Germany
responded by banning male migrants.
How did the regressive left respond to
that?
They complain.
They said it was racist.
They intimidated.
They forced the swimming pool into
lifting the ban because again,
they can't entertain the notion that
some cultures are worse than others and
that's the heart of regressives.
It's this utopian idea that everybody's
the same and everybody's equal.
Even though this is bad behavior that we
shouldn't be accepting and embracing in
the west.
Yeah,
and there's really no end to it.
Right.
That's why this snake will eventually
eat its tail because,
you know,
if you look what happened in Germany,
uh,
you know,
right on New Year's with,
with all the rapes and all the sexual
attacks on women,
suddenly all the regressives we're
defending basically the perpetrators,
they kept saying not all Muslims,
all this stuff.
Nobody was saying all Muslims.
People were saying the specific people
here who did this,
they have these set of values.
They're the ones that did it.
That's what a rational person would say.
We didn't say this is condemning every
single person that believes in this and
yet they go to defend that.
So they throw women under the bus.
So it's like they have their pecking
order and in this case women came below
the migrants because the migrants are
mostly Muslim.
Yeah.
That whole oppression,
Olympics idea.
And when it came out in Cologne,
it later emerged that most of the
perpetrators were not newly arrived
refugees.
They were migrants who had been there
for several years and they're
aggressive.
Celebrates.
Yeah.
How dare you demonize the refugees.
This was done by migrants.
Okay.
So migrants who were supposedly
assimilated,
they've been there for years and yet
this is the kind of behavior they're
engaging in and that's something to
celebrate.
I mean,
that's again,
that shines light on the heart,
progressivism,
and as he said,
you know,
after every single terror attack,
we hear the same thing again and again,
don't blame Islam.
Not all Muslims are terrorists.
Nobody ever suggested that.
That's never been part of the debate.
They try and frame the debate so it
becomes that because they can't win when
you actually drill down,
you know,
into the statistics and show that this
isn't a tiny minority of people.
This is what I bang on about again and
again,
you know,
I make videos saying Islam is not
religion of peace.
Get death threats as a result of it.
I guess to prove that it isn't a
religion of peace,
but I mean you can look at the
statistics.
This is not a tiny minority of people.
This is a problem within Islam.
This is why we need to support the
voices of reform within Islam.
So Pew had a poll,
for example,
the percentage of Muslims who think that
suicide bombings are justified under
some circumstances.
They asked Muslims in European
countries,
so in France,
31 percent of adult Muslims over the age
of 30.
You think that suicide bombings or
sometimes justify,
if you look at young people aged 18 to
29,
that goes up to 42 percent think that
suicide bombings or sometimes justify,
and it's similar in Spain,
22 percent of adults think the same.
Germany,
10 percent and 22 percent of those aged
18 to 29 think that suicide bombings or
justify.
You've also got huge numbers of Muslims
throughout your trip.
In France for example,
27 percent of Muslims aged 18 to 24
support isis.
So again,
this is not a tiny fringe minority of
people.
Twenty one percent of Syrian support
Isis.
These are the people who were bringing
in.
So it's this lie that the Islamophobia
industry upholds the.
It's just a,
you know,
a tiny fringe minority.
It isn't.
And the facts,
the stats prove that.
Yeah.
What do you think of the Word
Islamophobia?
I assume you're not a fan of the word
itself.
I think it's.
It's an imaginary world.
You can't fear a set of ideas.
You can fear actions that people might
do,
and Islam itself says a lot of bad
things about infidel is like a the two
of us.
Right?
So it's not an irrational fear to fear
this set of ideas.
It's just,
this is just a made up word,
right?
That doesn't discount that there might
be bigotry towards Muslim people,
but the word itself is a slippery slope.
Right?
Well,
it's become interchangeable with racist,
doesn't it?
I mean,
at this point,
the Islamophobia industry is bolstered
and exaggerate it to such an extent.
I mean,
there are Islamophobic attacks and
they're horrible and we shouldn't cry
them,
but it's presented.
Those are anti Muslim attacks,
right?
Not,
not Islamophobic attacks.
Right.
They're not afraid of the idea of
something they're.
They're afraid of the people.
Right?
Yeah.
That was.
That was a basically racist attacks.
But if you look at actual hate crimes
that far outweighed by antisemitic
attacks,
for example,
in in most western countries.
So I think that's exaggerated.
We saw that again in molenbeek just the
other day where the media reported that
a right wing protests had run over.
A Muslim woman later turned out that it
was a Muslim teen from molenbeek who ran
over the Muslim woman.
So there are these,
these fake Islamophobic attacks.
It was another one on Wall Street where
a Muslim woman says she was slashed
across the face.
Then Islamophobic attacks turned out.
It was completely made of.
So again,
you know this point,
why not own it?
Why not say yes?
I'm afraid of an ideology that supports
Sharia law,
that supports stoning women to death,
executing homosexuals killing people who
leave the faith of Islam.
Yes,
I'm very afraid of importing those kinds
of ideas into the west and when,
for example,
50 percent of Muslims of American
Muslims support the right to live under
Sharia law in the United States.
That's a problem.
And I'm going to call attention to that
figure because it's,
it's way too high.
And to call attention to that figure is
not to be Islamophobic,
it's to be rightly concerned about these
intolerant beliefs being imported into
the west as they now are in such great
numbers.
So for people like us that want to have
honest discussions about this without
bigotry and without hyperbole,
and I know it's very hard to do and we
don't win any points for doing this
really,
but for people like us and I know it's a
growing movement,
should we start thinking of Islam more
as a political ideology than a religion?
Because people,
no matter how many times we separate
ideas versus people religion first
people,
people can't seem to do it.
They just.
There's a certain amount of people,
they cannot detangle these two things.
But I'm starting to think that if we
start describing these actions as
political actions,
killing gays,
not good.
You know what I mean?
A oppressing women not good.
If these were political,
a political party was pushing these
ideas,
the left would be completely against it.
So is that sort of how we have to.
Not to give up our tactics publicly
right now,
but is that how we have to start
focusing on this argument?
I think it is exactly.
I mean,
you know,
Sam Harris Majeed was dave outline the
fact that this is not just jihad is the
problem,
isn't just jihadist.
Yes,
you can point to that and say that's a
tiny minority,
but the main problem is Islam is,
you know,
I agreed with Obama when he said
terrorism is not an existential threat.
I mean we're not going to all be killed
by terrorists is not going to be such a
massive,
you know,
onset of terrorist attacks that it
proves an existential threat.
But when you import these ideas that are
incompatible with western,
then that's a direct why quality of
life,
our culture and the entire underpinnings
of Western society as a free liberal
tolerant society.
So we have to emphasize that distinction
that there are not just jihadist Islam
Miss.
I mean look at deadline there in
molenbeek and Brussels.
He was protected for months after the
Paris massacre by his friends and
neighbors.
Okay.
Then not jihadists.
They haven't gone out and slaughtered
anybody,
but they were protecting a jihadist
because there is limits and this is,
this is the problem when we get huge
numbers of people moving into Western
societies,
they create these ghettos,
they create centers of power and then
isis comes out and its manifesto and
says,
we're going to encourage the creation of
these ghettos in the west to radicalize
these populations to support our cause.
Then that's a problem.
I mean,
you can get an AK 47 on the streets and
Malombe within a few hours for 400
euros.
That's doesn't just arise out jihadists.
That's this whole is support network
that protects Solo Abdeslam for example.
So that's the distinction we need to
emphasize to leftists and regressives.
Again,
it's not a tiny minority.
We have to include Islamis as part of
the problem and if you include them as
part of the problem,
the figures show that it's a distressing
proportion of people who support,
advocate and promote these intolerant
believers.
Yeah,
and I know no matter how many times we
repeat the difference between jihadists
and Islamists and the average nominal
Muslim somehow that just can't get
through to a certain amount of people.
But before I let you go,
I want to dive into the immigration
thing a little deeper because you've
done a lot on it and when I've watched
some of your videos,
you know,
we really,
in the mainstream media in the United
States,
we barely talk about it.
I would guess that if you watch CNN 24
hours today,
um,
that you wouldn't see one story on it,
literally not one minute on it.
Um,
and then I watch your videos and some
other people and I will watch some stuff
on the BBC or something like that and I
get a sense that it's a big problem and
I get tons of messages.
Mainly I'm getting a ton of stuff from
Sweden especially talking about this.
Would you say out of a 10 where,
where is this thing hat right now?
I mean,
is this really as bad as the videos that
you put out?
It makes it sound like there's a massive
crisis right now,
or is some of it overblown?
Is it different for every country?
I'm still struggling to get a hold on
it.
Well,
it's different for every country.
That tends to be a tipping point.
When a country goes above,
for example,
six to seven percent Muslim population,
that's when you get the no go areas,
which the media still claims is a
conspiracy theory.
I got chased out of one in molenbeek.
I can attest to the fact that it's not.
So that's the kind of tipping point.
I mean to illustrate this,
you can look at the prison in these
different European countries.
So for example,
Belgium,
which of course just stuff that the
Brussels attack,
the Muslim population is around six
percent,
but the prison population of Belgium
comprises 45 percent Muslims.
The 45 percent of the prisoners in
Belgium.
A Muslims,
despite the fact they only make up six
percent of the population.
You look at friends,
six to 10 percent Muslim population,
but the prison population is 70 percent
Muslims.
Same in Spain.
Muslim population,
three point seven percent.
Prison population is 70 percent Muslim,
so obviously something is broken here
and we were getting the correct word,
seeing the creation of more of these
ghettos,
they don't assimilate for our political
leaders want to bring them in for their
own agenda,
which is the goal of imposing huge
numbers of people from the third world
to vote for bigger government.
If you look at polls conducted amongst
Muslims,
they typically support expanded welfare
state and they vote once they become
citizens for bigger government,
so they've placed Europe security.
They placed our entire social cohesion
under grave danger in favor of.
Of advancing this political agenda.
Yeah.
Do you think it was that in the case of
like Angola Merkel,
do you think it was that calculated like
I.
my sense is that there was some level of
guilt because of the Holocaust and
Germany's stills trying to deal with
that,
that they partly we're trying to do
something good here.
They brought this.
I think it's one point two or one point
3 million people in and that it is just
crushing the system and creating all
this resentment and a country that has,
has a tough history with xenophobia.
It's only gonna get worse and it's hard
to believe,
uh,
that she knowingly did this even if it
was just to get votes,
which it's not working right,
because it didn't,
some of the right parties just win
elections.
No,
not.
It was a reaction to that.
I mean,
for the past couple of years you've had
a basically a conservative backlash
sweeping Europe,
the,
your elections in 2014 proof of that.
So it was a backlash to that.
Now of course,
500,000
migrants who have come into Germany
haven't registered with all authorities,
so that's going to become a massive
problem.
But yeah,
a lot of it was virtue signaling on
steroids.
Right.
So you had,
you know,
the German Green Party politician,
Stephanie,
Yvonne Berg,
she got up in front of the German
parliament and said,
Whoa,
ass city will change radically.
I hold it in 20,
30 years.
They will no longer be a German majority
in our city and that's a good thing.
So she said that simply as a way of
pissing off the right wing in Germany,
they would bring in these migrants to
displace the German population.
So it,
part of it is virtue on steroids.
Part of it is that guilt about the
Nazis,
which of course we have to remember only
a minority of the German population
actually supported the Nazi party in the
19 thirties.
So I would argue that,
why would you punish,
you know,
German citizens,
taxpayers now we've got Germans being
kicked out of social housing to be
replaced by migrants over one point,
2 million migrants brought in already
over the past year.
And again,
politicians celebrating the
demographics,
suicide of their country and it clearly
isn't working because every single day
we have these cases of people being
raped now,
the primary victims of rape of Muslim
women and girls in these moment,
migrant camps.
But now you see these reports of,
you know,
African migrants raping boys in swimming
pools.
And quite frankly,
I'm sick of seeing it every single day.
This is a bad culture.
These people aren't being assimilated.
If you import huge numbers of people at
break neck speed with no clear plan on
how to assimilate them,
there's going to be bedlam,
there's going to be chaos and that's now
why top military chiefs in Sweden and
Switzerland in Norway or warning that
this could lead to civil unrest,
an outright war.
Basically if it.
If it continues this way.
Yeah man,
I wanted to end with you on a positive
note.
Can we figure out how to do that?
Whereas Europe going to be in 10 years,
any hope?
Well,
as I said,
I mean a lot of these parties are being
voted out of power and that's been
happening for the past couple of years.
So there is a kind of backlash against
it.
You know,
I'm all for limited skilled immigration.
I don't think that's healthy for a
society,
but the way it's going,
you know,
300,000
immigrants every year coming into the
United Kingdom.
We've only got a population of $60
million and that's after the.
That's the number after the other ones
have left.
So it's going to become overwhelming,
it's going to cause more problems,
more riots,
but from a positive perspective,
you know my videos,
your videos about this or reaching a
huge audience because the media
continually lies about it.
They don't point out that 72 percent of
the people coming in and man,
these are generally not families.
Four fifths of them at one point weren't
even Syrians,
but the fact that I can do a video about
this and it gets over a million views,
proves that people are thirsty for the
truth and we are shaping the narrative
and eventually the hope is that that
will change government policy by sheer
force of pressure.
All right,
well listen,
that's exactly why I try to have these
conversations and that's why I liked the
work you do and you know what?
Here's what we'll do for anyone that's
watching this that thinks that anything
that Paul said was conspiratorial or
unfactual,
tag me on twitter with them and we'll
talk some of this stuff out.
Will you make that commitment?
We'll talk some this stuff out with a
couple of the people.
Not Everybody I'll do it.
You'll do it all right,
so it's at prison planet on twitter and
he's doing all these videos on youtube
and I thank you guys for watching and
Paul,
you stayed up late for me so I
appreciate it.
Thanks a lot,
man.